i'm in australia so i'm in the future
i'm in the future guys guess what it's
still covered
i'm going to ask a a a question that's
nothing to do with the movie but i'm
curious about
uh for each of you when did you actually
think you could
be an actor and do this for a living and
pay rent
you know like at what point in your life
did you feel like you sort of made it
i don't think anybody ever thinks
they've made it like i genuinely think
i genuinely think if you ask tom hanks
he would probably say
you know it could really dry up in the
next year or two you just don't know
like i think everybody has that concern
um but when i was about 25 or so i did a
couple jobs where i thought oh i've got
something to contribute i began to
believe in my ability to contribute at
least
i knew i wouldn't do it all the time i
think that really helps
that when you're not working you think
no but i do have something to offer
someone
just uh nobody believes me at the moment
i would say that's the that was probably
it for me what about you rose
um i think i started so young in
australia but i remember my first
job going oh my goodness i got paid to
do
this and i'm not from a family of actors
or people in the business so that was
kind of revelatory to go oh what
this is something i've loved doing is
child it's clout you know and so on and
then to actually be
employed was quite extraordinary
what do you think for people that are
fascinated about the behind the scenes
of a making
of the making of this film or movies in
general what do you think might surprise
people to learn about the making of
peter rabbit or peter rabbit too
well i mean it's so technical i i don't
know how surprised people would or
wouldn't be about that because it's
obviously
animate you know there's part of it
that's like animated rabbits you know
um but will glock is a specific director
you know he's high energy and
he's always trying ideas and it's very
spontaneous and changes all the time so
it's a little bit unpredictable
and i think maybe that that that
surprises anyone who comes on set
they're always like wow what are you
guys doing so i had to roll down the
hill for a little bit of it
and the people all the stunt team went
out that morning they'd been there for
two hours and three hours before we got
there
trying to remove all the rocks from the
hill on the way down because it's an
actual hill
and they were worried i was going to
smack my head or break my
you know leg or something like that so
i'd say that's quite surprising and also
quite lovely of them to do it they
didn't get rid of the stinging nettles
and that's still
something like there's a problem i have
with them yeah
you know you know diligent to a point i
would say
i actually thought you really went for
it in this movie you uh you made me
laugh at the time
it looks like you could have gotten hurt
making this film or was i wrong
you get a little bit hurt people like me
can't do
little bits of stunts and all the rest
of it and not get a little bit hurt
that's just going to be the way that it
goes so i'm not built for impact
these this thing doesn't work for impact
so yeah you get a bit hurt but that's
part of the fun
for both of you um was it any easier of
like
using pure imagination to imagine the
rabbits are there you don't imagine the
first movie you must have been like
this is crazy and now it must be a
little bit easier
the more confident just knowing the tone
and then it just it's just
technical it's very technical and all
the different heads of department and
understanding everybody's
so critical to making this work it's
they're not trying to just
you know everyone is working really hard
on what they have to do
and so it's even yeah it's just being
aware of that and
but i enjoyed this more because i was i
knew how
and i also just knew that the joy it
brings kids to see these animals like
they just couldn't be
more delighted with those characters and
that's the best
most satisfying experience as an actor
to see that joy
that was a good answer
[Laughter]
we'll stop there and i'll just say good
luck with the rest of your speed dating
thank you so much for your time